we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here is a voicemail with a different
perspective on kovid at this point i
don't know if this is serious or a
satire
so as we begin the third year of covert
i realized
that covert can't be real
this is just the new version of the
truman show right and eventually we're
going to figure out
it was all just
a tv show
thanks you do a great job have a good
day i assume that it's a satire but uh
the truman show a fantastic film
starring jim carrey
um in which
he doesn't know that he has been raised
in a television program
and uh the real world uh population is
watching it and i mean listen
um i am open to the idea that we're
living in a simulation i don't know that
covid is that proof i'll just leave it
at that we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about karl rove
saying hey these republicans they got to
just go hard against the trump rioters
this is not something you want to mess
around with we will talk about the
ethical and legal questions surrounding
sean hannity and his text messages
related to the trump riots and we will
talk about you know i know it's 2022
maricopa county arizona officials are
finally ready to say the 2020 election
is over they seem ready to say we're
we're not going to get arizona flipped
from joe biden to donald trump they're
accepting it now in january of 2022. all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com